the president's top defenders are out
working hard blaming everybody and
everything except for his own policies
it's been a rough and tough year and we
knew it would be we inherited a country
where four thousand people a day four
thousand people a day we're dying from
covington the country is in a bad place
uh we
have a pandemic and now we're trying
to bring the economy back and you've got
all of these other things happening so
the country's in a bad place
it was a real tough time to become
president of the united states
oh wow really
a piece from the hill with this quote
today's election results prompted some
soul searching among democrats about
whether the party misread the public's
desire for sweeping change republicans
are only too glad to say democrats
misread the mandate from president
biden's victory a year ago over former
president trump pete hexset is co-host
of fox and friends weekend good to see
you pete
there is so much news oh you too
so much meat on the bone here for what
democrats in the white house and the
administration didn't see let's start
there uh yeah what they what they
thought they saw was a mandate you're
right here we are a year later and
they're still blaming
donald trump that that's that's not
leadership that's that's making excuses
that's obfuscation uh that's creating a
straw man that you're running against
even though you have all the levers of
power take coven for example they'll
never acknowledge uh at all that the
vaccines they rely completely on are
ones that were delivered by operation
warp speed and they dismissed as
potentially dangerous before they became
president and vice president they'll
never acknowledge that they'll never
acknowledge china's role and actually
take them on for it when donald trump
was willing to do that from the very
beginning but the harris this is the
first time we've talked since the
elections last week and when you look at
the priorities of democrats versus the
realities of americans that's what
happened in virginia new jersey in
minneapolis in virginia it was education
and classrooms in new jersey it was
overwhelming draconian coveted mass
mandates and vaccine mandates and in
minneapolis where they voted against
defunding the police it was all about
simple public safety even though
minneapolis is a 70 30 democrat to
republican city so while joe biden is
falling asleep in europe at weather
conferences and pushing for electric
cars
people are are having to figure out do i
have to wear a mask or not put it on my
kid do i have to get the vaccine or not
what are my kids actually being taught
in the classroom why is my border wide
open are people being flown to my
neighborhood uh in my my city in in the
middle of the night is crime going up in
my neighborhood what's everything's
costing more for me in inflation and
they can't explain the the the supply
chain crisis so these are things that
hit voters where they're at joe biden
has delivered on none of them just real
quickly james clyburn top three in power
in the house right his office is right
next to nancy pelosi's i've been in
there
and he says that bad time to become
president
they broke a bunch of stuff in this car
in this country like inflation yet it's
a bad time for biden to be president
imagine how it is as an american who's
got to go to the store or go to the gas
store imagine how it is for them
by the way there is no joe biden without
james clyburn uh he was the one that was
fundamental in that pivotal race in
south carolina there's absolutely no
doubt about it yep but think about it
they're killing it killing energy
pipelines uh and we have record uh
reliance upon opec and record prices now
they want to kill another pipeline look
at what they did at the border
money to not build the wall it's it's
amazing they created this i want to
pause just right there pete you can pick
it right back up so hardly anybody's
talking about the details of this but i
want to president biden's energy
secretary says americans had
better brace for this winter's bills
should americans in what will likely be
a cold winter most of them are expect to
pay
higher
prices for heating their homes yeah
this is going to happen it will be uh it
will be more expensive this year than
last year we have the same problem in
fuels that the supply chains have which
is that the oil and gas companies are
not flipping the switch as quickly as
the demand requires more expensive than
a year when most of us were locked
inside our homes
wow in fact a report from the energy
information administration finds we'll
all likely pay more for everything from
propane to natural gas not to mention
the gas prices at the pump the national
average cost of gasoline gallon right
now three dollars and 43 cents it's
close to five dollars in many parts of
the country and after taking heat for
canceling the keystone pipeline let's
get back to what pete hexset was just
talking about i asked my team for a map
because i want everybody to focus the
president is going to do this again he's
reportedly looking at shutting down
another energy pipeline the line five in
michigan
in a letter to the president 13
lawmakers wrote should this pipeline be
shut down tens of thousands of jobs
would be lost across the region as we
enter the winter months the termination
of line five will undoubtedly further
exacerbate shortages price increases and
home heating fuels like natural gas
propane at a time when americans are
already facing rapidly rising
energy prices say it with me line five
michigan let's get to know it pete
be right just like we got to know the
keystone xl pipeline rather than
rely on or work on energy with canada uh
who who you know is a reliable trading
partner to get our energy sources
and then preventing our own companies
from exploration whether it's fracking
natural gas all of that
we are begging opec
begging opec a cartel
to increa to increase its supply so that
our prices can go down when just a year
ago as you laid out harris we were
effectively energy independent helping
to drive down global energy prices
because of the supply we could add and
the demand we could meet this is
democrats
what all they're doing is bowing to
extremist environmentalist groups who
are saying that a pipeline like this is
unsafe to the environment when i i just
have a feeling based on the working
folks that are working on that pipeline
they're going to make damn sure that
pipeline works and is not uh it does
does not leak does not create
environmental concerns and it's all of
us who pay the price when you say 54 in
energy energy price increases harris you
know what you and i can probably handle
that and and and a lot of other people
on this channel in the world media that
that's fine maybe but think about an
average family in in the upper midwest
who's going to go through a cold winter
and it's looking at 50 40 30 increase in
heating uh and energy prices that's
catastrophic that is a regressive tax
against the least among us the democrats
say they won't raise taxes on on low
wage earners that's exactly what this is
yeah look at that and by the way i was
reading digging deeper because you know
i'm going to do it all week long now
enbridge we're going to be we'll hashtag
that right
because this isn't this isn't the right
thing to do to do something like this
and not even tell the american people
the truth about it uh down chain supply
chain petroleum products it's more than
just the people in the upper midwest oh
we'll learn
and by the way by the way harris the
energy secretary you know that clip she
laughed laughed openly when asked if she
had a plan to address our energy needs
she laughed and said what do you want me
to do a wave of magic wand it reminded
me of when barack obama said
what do you want me to wave a magic wand
to bring manufacturing jobs back well
donald trump actually focused on that
and tried to make it happen they're
doing the opposite as it pertains to
energy yeah secretary granholm we would
like to see that magic wand if you could
possibly take that out
saturday night live face blowback for
mocking virginia's lieutenant governor
elect and retired marine winsome sears
republican winsome sears seen here
attempting suicide by cop
was elected
was elected as virginia's first black
female lieutenant governor but this is
actually a win for democrats because
nothing will get republicans to support
gun control faster than this picture
the winsome camp posted that photo in
response to criticism from former espn
broadcaster jamil hill and after winsom
and glenn younkin upset democrats in
virginia last week hill tweeted it's not
the messaging folks the country simply
loves white supremacy team winsum
responded with that photo and captioned
we beg to differ
pete
yes all of those uh white supremacists
that came out and voted for a black
female lieutenant governor uh and the
the laughter in that clip as if me as a
supporter of the second amendment cares
whether it's a black or white person a
man or a woman who has the right to
defend themselves they're the ones
making everything about race they're the
ones being racist about it we are
grateful for the service of someone like
winsome sears her willingness to speak
truth and yet they say when she speaks
that truth she's speaking white words
from a black mouth i mean it is they are
the racists in that equation i'm not
looking at her race i'm looking at what
she'll do for virginia as a conservative
and that's a beautiful thing well i need
to put that on a loop and play it for a
whole lot of folks so they hear it over
and over because that's so true
uh pete heck seth always good to have
you in focus and on a monday to kick
yours thank you
programming note now on the fox nation
app speaking of pete
the patriot awards are coming up next
week wednesday november 17th at the hard
rock live theater in hollywood florida
pete heg sets will be there along with
some of your favorite fox personalities
get your ticket at foxnation.com
patriot awards